should titanfall to have a competitive
mode yes and no yes because this game
should have a competitive mode because
it extends the longitude of the game by
having the players strive to be the
highest and earn a reward now these
rewards could be their chance of having
their own prime tighten skin for the
Titan of their choosing adding new
player Titan skins in general or
anything that isn't paid a win because
respawn did state that they do not want
this game to be like cod and have
orangey type loot drops or anything pay
to win and I'm glad they have stuck to
their word the only reason I said no at
the beginning was because this could
divide the playerbase even more than and
we don't want that so good idea that I
came up with is to have a competitive
mode similar to Gears of War now none of
you played gears of war seeing as some
of you could be on PlayStation for the
older PC the way Gears of War works is
that you have a competitive ranking for
different game modes one of them could
be one of the game modes is TDM and the
other one is I think domination or our
point I forgot the names excuse me for
that but you go through five placement
matches and you could be lets say bronze
3 and TDM book like maybe silver 3 in
like a domination type game it all and
it all kind of suits you out between the
playerbase there so you'd be in people
with similar different ranking levels
and such so for titan falls case you
could be a gold too let's say in bounty
hunt will be like a bronze 3 and last
tight and standing it's just the same
game modes but we just have a ranking on
top of it for us to strive to do more of
stuff and play the game more now you
could argue that this player base is
still kind of being divided in the
ranking but honestly these are just my
personal opinions you don't have to take
these literally is just some ideas I had
last night and I thought that I would
share them with all of you anyway this
is going to be a real quick video of if
there should be a competitive mode or
not I want to hear York I want to I want
you all to comment below when you watch
this video
your opinion should there be a
competitive mode should there not be and
if there is if there should be tell me
why and if there isn't still tell me why
there shouldn't be I'd like to hear your
opinions on this like this video if you
did enjoy like I said before this is
just a quick video a few ideas I came up
with last night that I thought would be
nice for a video how about anyway guys
subscribe if you're new to this i'll be
posting more titanfall videos in the
next coming weeks so don't you worry
about that and i have a great day guys
peace out